thank you for staying with us here at 4
30 I'm Denise Valdez I'm Kirsten Joyce
we start with breaking news of this half
hour a shooting investigation in the
East Valley 8 news now reporter Sasha
Loftus is at the scene with more details
Sasha
Denise and Kirsten still a pretty active
scene here behind me near Eastern and
Bonanza you can see part of the road
blocked off here the RTC bus police say
this shooting happened on part of that
investigation now we're told this
happened just about an hour ago around
three o'clock this afternoon police say
someone was shot on an RTC bus they say
one person is in the hospital and
they're still searching for the suspect
connected to this situation now schools
in the area were told were put on
lockdown as a precaution that is
according to Metro as for road closures
watch for delays here at the
intersection as that investigation
continues parts of both Eastern as you
can see here and Bonanza are still shut
down and probably will be for a while
longer no word on when this
investigation is set to wrap up we'll of
course continue to follow this for you
both on air and online so stay with 8
news now for the very latest reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now